hello and welcome to the 2014 u.s chess
championships and u.s women's here in
the capital of chess in america st louis
we're in the beautiful central west end
right across the street from the world
chess hall of fame
and for the sixth year running we've
been hosting the us chess championship
and the us women's at the st louis chess
club
some big matchups today mouth-watering
that's right as we enter
round six of the us championship and
around five of us women
so players are shaking hands
wearing their snazzy st louis chess club
vests and wait a second a swarm where's
the bow just a second we need a close-up
to make sure no bow today i don't know i
don't know how i feel about that
i'm jennifer shahady and i'm your host
today
at the u.s championship in u.s women's
i'm with grandmaster yester sarwan and
maurice ashley
and let's take a look at the sandmans
well alexander lenderman leads our
tournament the new yorker is impressing
everyone he's a queen ahead of the pack
but what a pack it is
just the point behind him the olympic
team
tarakamsky onoshuk okobian gurav
the only one we're missing is of course
uh
hikaru nakamura definitely
our leader in the u.s women's
championship i read a crash playing some
fantastic chess and she's a half a point
head to the field
her
main rival anna zatonski
yesterday looked like she might lose but
in the end she held a draw with the
fortress and so she's right behind irena
crash
and grandmaster maurice ashley has some
sufferers on the key matchups of the day
indeed we are in the middle of these
championships and the players are
jockeying for position getting ready for
the stretch run on the women's side we
have the big matchup of course between
tatev abrahamian and our leader irina
crush tatev in previous years a few
years ago was a runner-up in these
events she has never broken through to
the top so she is looking to see what
she could do against our five-time
champion today on the men's side it's a
battle of the big dogs you've got
alexander onashuk could have been number
two seated in this tournament just by
some percentage points almost but he's
going to have to face off against the
four-time champion godokonski who had
some strange thing to say about not
winning the championship this year
feeling like it was time for a new
champion but i doubt it he's going to be
tested today and we'll see how that
matchup goes of course our leader
alexander lindemann today he plays
shanklin but look at the rest of the
players he's going to have to face
godikomski and onuschuk waiting in the
wings and he will have the black pieces
so going up against the middle of the
order will be alexander lindemann there
we see onas getting his game face on
today's matchup will be key as the
players are ready to go into the stretch
run of the u.s championships back to you
jenna yes
boy jen i'm thinking that today we've
got some mouth-watering match-ups really
in the women's section actually the four
leaders of the women section all
uh square off against each other
and in the men's section that big match
between oni shook and kamsky that's
going to be i hope that's going to be
our game of the day because those two
are for the last 10 years have been the
centerpiece of american chess on the
foundation are his eyes open
he he seems to be just meditating and
getting the
mood getting on his game face he's very
stoic
during the game
uh here he almost seems kind of
far too relaxed though
i don't know he seems oh yeah i mean
he's
that's
look at it
he looks sharp his eyes are blazing in
in the interviews and in person but over
the board he has some scary looks he
does he does he he he he he can be sharp
when he looks at you dead in the eye
like what are you doing young man
well he's a competitor he came down and
said that he thinks the longer the event
and more favored him yes because like
you mentioned a triathlete uh in great
physical
uh conditioning and he thinks that as
the event
you know it's a marathon it's not a
sprint he thinks that towards those
later rounds the money rounds uh he'll
be doing very well the traditional
handshake as godakomsky uh starts the
clock and we do have what i had expected
a queen pawn opening in our featured
game
and it looks like a dutch my first
i couldn't see the webcam
clearly enough
but uh one interesting thing is
ownership
hasn't had a great record against kamsky
kamsky's comfortably drawn against him
quite a lot
and kamsky's won two games but they were
both of the white pieces so they're
head-to-head match-ups exactly
so can ownership break through and score
his first victory against gadokamsky
big question indeed
i can tell you that both players have
such a solid style it really they really
have a difficult time creating chances
against one another that's probably why
you're absolutely right and uh
i was wrong the bow remains
it was just a little hidden from my
camera there you go and it's that way
because of the background with the white
uh against the wall that's where the bow
kind of
got hidden and she's playing against
anna satonski so
on a four-time champion
uh this is a very very big test for
ashrita
exactly but we should point out
that does play in a lot of open
tournaments so she's not used she's not
like she's totally unused to playing
stronger opponents right without
question but the difference is is that
it's every single day if you play in an
open tournament you're going to get some
easy pairings and there is there are no
easy players in this field and anna
zatonski is uh
really a big favorite
absolutely a very big favorite although
i think sometimes the readings could be
a little bit misleading just because
sometimes these players have trouble
catching up their fee day ratings
typically
if you look at the uscf ratings she's
really only
like she's like maybe 30 points behind
alyssa
80 points behind victoria
not
as dramatic as her fide differentials
right and because she's so young
her style isn't set in stone or anything
like that she's developing
very very rapidly and
if you coach youngsters
you can get surprised by how much
progress they make so quickly it's like
they they kind of accelerate they lurch
forward so uh for sure uh uh sharitha is
underrated and by the time this
tournament is completed i expect her
rating will have gone up quite a bit
absolutely and even looking at the
ratings some of her opponents only 50
points ahead of her so
we we uh i think can expect more good
things out of her without question
and shall we have a look at our games uh
let's see what we're getting in the
openings any surprises today another key
game of course we're always keeping a
close eye on our tournament leader
alexander landerman today playing
against sam shanklin
uh-huh i don't have any updated moves on
my no greetings
no green juices game
i don't know if i i don't like that
no soylent no no soylent green
that's terrible
that's some reference you know what that
is that's a superfood it's going to
replace food yes
but you know where they get it right
it's soylent green no no no no no
there's a new company oh i'm sorry
startup in california really i didn't
mention despite that story oh okay
oh the idea is that uh it's going to
replace regular food and that people can
just subscribe to sully and then never
have to eat it sounds miserable doesn't
it it does
oh no no liquid food no no
all right just a second let me refresh
my board yeah refresher important let's
take a look at that opening in lenderman
chankman how's that going yesterday we
saw that lenderman played very combative
chess despite the fact that he was a
point ahead of the field and well half a
point last round and we really like to
see that
absolutely now shanklin has won against
lendermen in the past so that they
haven't played that many times
so shanklin defeated lenderman and
foxwoods a few years ago
and chanklas usually had the white
pieces in their battles
at the championships in 09 and 2010
shanklin drew with the white pieces so
this is leonard's chance to get a crack
with white
and at some point we imagine that green
will join the battle exactly i'm still
i'm having a little difficulties on my
monitor
let me just throw it to maurice if he
has some updated moves because i still
don't have updated moves looks like
we're getting a few and we'll get more
well yes thanks just uh pulling up this
game right here between ownership and
kamsky and we see the super solid slav
on the board the a6 slav then combined
with g6 komski has done this in the past
this stuff is so hard to break down this
wall of pawns just keeping the white
pieces out i've actually yet to see
someone really take it to kamsky in this
position he just loves to play super
solid super strong this is also an
indication that he may just be happy to
equalize with the black pieces knowing
that he's facing such a formidable
opponent as is alexander ownership and
ownership
no doubt has something prepared against
this line because he knows this is what
komski plays so we'll see what happens
there and another key matchup we have
linderman shanklin they haven't really
gone anywhere as lindemann has really
been focused on this very basic move
order just a queen's gambit
decline so far but only a couple of
moves in linderman seem seems uh very
much focused now and on another board on
the keyboard in this tournament
abrahamian versus crush
we see here that our that crush uh has
chosen um to play this line is it a
kalashnikov it looks like uh this
variation
is uh known to be
pretty good for white
but at and abrahamian herself loves to
play e4 and these kind of double-edged
sharp openings so i would expect a crazy
game here
no doubt about it now we switch over to
the other key matchup on the women's
side eswara and zatonski both chasing
irina crush as warren
as has played this french line well
zatonski has but this line of the french
much more open piece play much more free
these kind of lines lead to good
positions for white almost white doesn't
often lose this type of very easy to
play position so eswara might be pleased
she's already in a line that's
comfortable that's easy for her to play
and
you know a draw against zatonski would
be a huge achievement but i don't think
the kids thinking about a draw right now
she's playing for the win uh as much as
she can and already uh in thought move
bishop to e7 was played
yes uh this you've been in these kind of
positions before
looks pretty good for the white pieces
some kind of a comfortable situation to
be in not really being tested so much in
the crazy lines of the windower for
example what are your thoughts
well indeed uh this is of course the
rubenstein french
it was actually a favorite for a couple
of years of alexander morazevich
alexander morozevich like playing the
variation with bishop e7 bishop takes f6
g takes f6
going for a very imbalanced position
with the double pawns and it led to some
really wild affairs
but you're absolutely right maurice
percentage-wise white does do well
in this variation and it is hard for
black
to win black has to take a lot of risks
until we move to uh one of our other
games
how's the the irena crush game going
so irina crushed versus
and you know those have played some
epic battles in the past what if it was
i remember actually uh tatev um defeated
irina once in a wild sicilian and i
think uh irena got her back recently um
so we usually see some really exciting
games especially when tata is white
because tata really just likes to go for
it
and obviously that's the right strategy
being a point behind the field
and um
yeah every single game that they played
actually has been decisive every game
can you believe it wow ten games wow and
tatha's only won two but obviously she's
out there trying
swinging for the fences and all of that
all decisive games that is truly
remarkable by the way
eight
ten decisive games out of ten and do we
have another sicilian
yes it looks like uh one of these
kalashnikov
sicilians were where
arena
crush
is holding back
uh preparing to be play the move f7f5
to attack
white in the center as quickly as
possible well this sicilian has a bit of
a different character and instead of a
white slashing and burning it actually
kind of sometimes has the opposite
effect that white is trying to kind of
maintain the positional edge and hold
back black's activity so i think this is
a wise choice by arena
yes yes i
i i would agree with that and i um
uh was thinking that tatiaf might have
played instead of the move c2 c4 which
was a very positional move getting into
the types of games that you were just
describing i like the knight b1 c3 and
jumping to d5
quickly
even in those lines though it's still
more of a strategic battle than the kind
of wild you know f3 g4 h4 checkmate type
of sicilians but you know what you can't
always get what you want and the
kalashnikov and this feshnikov don't
really allow that type of crazy
attacking that's true but on the other
hand they give positional concessions so
maurice what do you think of that
the opening battle i read a question
tata
well i think that irina is playing
something that she normally simply does
not play and that tatev has been caught
by surprise and is trying to show that
she is not so surprised in this
situation i don't recall this variation
being a part of irina crush's practice i
must say that her trainer uh
khakishvili georgie kakis really
he also trains alexander lenderman so at
the moment this coach has
both his charges tied for first place
and their preparation has been quite
excellent as well so kudos to him for
maybe catching the opponent unawares
picking the right lines for them to play
and preparing them with confidence
because you see that it's really showing
in this tournament so far we go back to
the game between linderman and shanklin
and we see this variation of the queen's
gambit decline very sharp has already
happened with this dynamic play with the
pawns you see the bishop f4 line in this
line white often castles queen side or
should say sometimes castles queen side
and the game gets very very sharp so
expect a heated battle here i think that
linderman is going to be well prepared
in such a line and again we could go
back to that big battle between owner
chuck and komsky and you see the move a4
has been played in order to create some
kind of bind on the queen side i'm not
sure if this is a new move looks like a
move that's reasonable enough to play
but certainly not the kind of wild slash
and burn central formation that you
would expect it's going to be a turgid
battle there in the middle of the board
uh one other game that we should take a
look at is this game between friedel and
gorayev guerrero was doing so well
yesterday and it was a big disaster he
lost his game from what looked like a
very promising position against a kobe
and he just completely screwed it up and
ended up losing an end game now taking a
step back so needing to try to get back
in the winner's circle he's played this
very funky line of the modern with a6
it's a line i like to play against
low-rated players but i've never had
great respect for the line
but of course correav he's got some
thoughts he's got to somehow confuse
friedal and see if he can somehow get
back again with a win so that
he gets that bitter taste of the loss
out of his mouth in the meantime friday
looks very comfortable right now so
interesting opening starting here i
think that a lot of victories will be
seeing a lot of victories in this round
of the championships back to you guys
we're up but we got a
a game that we're going to be following
very closely lenderman champlain our
leader see how that's going yeah our
leader in the tournament alex lenderman
playing against sam shanklin sam as we
know is at 50 percent
and i had expected more from sam and
lenderman are definitely outperforming
his wildest expectations we had a queen
pawn opening with
d2 d4 by
our tournament leader
and sam who
usually plays a slav defense
this time instead of playing the c7 c6
law for which he's most well known as
plato queen's gambit declined with the
move e7 e6 let's see how the game
continued
all along
right straight down
the standard
pathways bishop f4
that's the second most popular move the
most popular move that we've been around
for hundreds of years is the move bishop
g5 so the move bishop f4
that was played
one of the things one of the drawbacks
of this move
is it does allow black an opportunity an
earlier opportunity than he otherwise
might have
for playing c7 c5 attacking white in the
center let's see if sam
followed
with the early c7 c5 queen c2 all very
standard and finally he does get in the
move c7 c5
rook d1 uh trade on d4
and
lenderman to think
lend him into play by the way it goes
without saying that throughout the
tournament so far in all of the rounds
lenderman's uh
opening preparation has simply been
outstanding there's just no other words
for it as he's constantly
surprised his opponents
so far in this tournament that the fact
that he's just paused
right here
uh causes me to think that sam may have
hit his target in surprising lendermen
well shanklin also a very well-prepared
opponent as well absolutely we have some
questions coming in some comments and
questions using the hashtag u.s chess
champs please hit us up on twitter
or you can email us at comments at st
louis chessclub.org and we are going to
be giving away some prizes some
chess.com memberships and the diamonds
she has kid.com memberships as well
um and axelaumer says
um when do you tend to spend the
majority of your clock time how much of
it is influenced by your opponent's
speed
well yasser actually touched on this
yesterday when he talked about sensing
the critical moment how the stronger the
player is the more they realize
when it is a critical moment and they
need to
you know really
spend their clock time right right
and how much is it influenced by your
opponent's speed well for good players
it's only influenced by our opponent's
speed in that
if our opponent's playing very quickly
we can't think on their time right so we
usually have to spend even more of our
own time as a result
but we're not trying to
play a game of ego or chicken and you
know if you move quickly i should move
quickly because i want to show that i'm
as good as you right that's
that's a
beginner's trap actually yes exactly
right
but i was going to say like like
yourself
it really depends upon the moment i'm
not influenced so much by my my
opponent's tempo
but one of the things i have seen here
at the saint louis chess club and
watching the tournaments that do take
place
is that a lot of players uh mismanage
their time by actually spending a lot of
time on obvious captures right and don't
do that just don't do that if you're if
somebody plays queen takes queen
check and there's only one move in the
position
play it right yeah they'll think well
what will happen after i take it and so
on yeah that is one thing i've noticed
about really good players that
i feel that
uh they
spend a lot of time but they don't spend
as much time on really obvious moves
whereas i used to get into time pressure
all the time and i think yes one of the
reasons was because
i would want to spend 20 to 30 seconds
on every move right even if it was like
an opening move or a capture and
um you know obviously
not as extreme as queen takes queen
because ice cream but right kind of on
that same level exactly where those
little things can eat up at you just
kind of like if you're i mean because
honestly time time management is like
making a budget
just like if you're making a budget for
your finances it might be
the little things like the starbucks
that eats up
items absolutely
one of the worst actually in terms of uh
time management was
david bronstein uh challenger to the
world champion michael bobbinic that
match ended 12-12 david bronstein once
spent 45 minutes
on his opening move as white
and after the game of journalist hassan
david
what were you thinking about during
these first 45 minutes and david
bronstein answered i was thinking about
what to play
so normally speaking
amongst the professional players when
you go into a game go into a game with a
clear head as to what you want to play
don't come to the game and sit down and
panic think oh maybe i shouldn't play
the french defense the defense i have
just been prepared for the last 30
minutes maybe i should play the rui
lopez so you're saying a us championship
or whatever important tournament you
prepare for is not the right time to
figure out what's better one d4 or one
c4 that is that is true that is for sure
we'll be able to tackle that
in 45 minutes anyway right but so what
else do you got for us we got other
questions
well i was going to say we also have
again as maurice described in two top
dogs
uh alex ownership gotta kamsky gotta
camps he's playing his favorite slaw of
defense they're still in the opening but
essentially what has happened in the
slav defense so far from the starting
position
alex opened up with a queen pawn d4
this was d5
c4 c6 and you just heard me talking
about sam shanklin
and
this move as the slav defense one of the
most popular moves defenses i should say
in the world's elite ghada has been
using it for years as his
is his favorite uh weapon
a7 a6
we've discussed this move before it
looks a little bit weird but
trying to possibly play b5 or k7
sometimes defends the b5 the b7 pawn and
as well as just threatening to capture
the c4 pawn and keep it right so we see
the move e2 e3 to
defend the pawn on c4 with the bishop
and now
g7 g6 this
line of play is not the most popular
amongst the top players but gada has had
stellar reserve results with it
it but somehow it just matches his style
very well so he likes playing
the king side fianchetto bishop e2
both players have now accomplished one
of their primary goals in the opening
which is king safety position both kings
are very safe
from the opening
and now a2 a4 okay that's a little bit
off the beaten path there
more standard i would think in this
position is the move b two b three
preparing uh to do something with the
bishop on c1 instead we see the move a2
a4
an interesting little wrinkle
gotta
match white with the move a6 a5 so what
god is trying to say is that i want to
post a
piece on the b4 square
queen
d1 to b3 so the idea behind this early
queen move is just to make it that much
more difficult for black to develop his
light squared bishop by keeping uh the
pawn on b7 under
target well no way on a circus is going
to be out of his preparation i mean he
knew that chemskin would probably play
this oh without question
yes and probably this so
he probably did something like 70 30.
exactly or you know it's funny though
because even if it's only 30 chance that
the greenfield would show up
he might have spent more time on it just
because it's more
critical
yeah in a sense the the lines are so
sharp you need to refresh right
to make sure that your mind is alert
whereas this is a slow play kind of game
yeah i mean but not only did he prepare
this he probably prepared it before the
tournament so that he could relax and
and run and swim and whatever he liked
to do to keep himself
less stressed a cross trainer rook d1
and now gata is thinking so here the
point is is that black's only liab
liability is his light squared bishop
white has a little
preponderance of space advantage thanks
to these pawns on d4 c4 but that's okay
all you need is one good uh square for
each of your pieces and i would
anticipate that gada would play knight
b8 to a6 with the idea of putting his
knight
on b4 which again would rather
stymie white's queen
again the players are still deep into
their preparations nothing special
happening here let's see if we can get
some more exciting action in some of the
other games and we also have some more
uh questions and comments coming in at a
u.s chess champ so
thanks guys for participating um one
question uh um from just for chess uh
is uh if leonard achieves success in
this tournament and more
will his game with ramirez in round
three be revered as much as some of
fishers
i think that's that's unlikely
bobby fischer no unlikely
absolutely a
legendary player who's inspired so many
players absolutely and that being said
if laura lenderman
has a wild surge and becomes world
champion that's what it would require
for
these games to be revered and uh without
question and obviously that is a long
road ahead but
i remember saying ever exactly i i
remember having a conversation many many
years ago with a soviet champion
a remarkable uh
remarkable player grand master left
sakes
and um
it was still at the time of the soviet
union
and love and i were just having these
very nice discussions and we started
talking about the fischer spassky match
1972 and i was mentioning to lev
how
impactful that single event was in my
life as a chess player and eventually
brought me a chess career as a
professional and lev was explaining to
me that he was a
a man from the soviet union he was
rooting for bobby fischer
wow he was rooting for bobby fischer and
this was such a shock for me
because i thought you know like
everyone would would be nationalistic
especially in the soviet unions and it
wasn't even permitted to even suggest
that you might uh favor the american in
the match and i asked him why
and it was simply that that uh
bobby was a hero for him too that that i
mean it was it was just that simple to
remember that because one of the things
that being able to travel to all these
countries and meet people from different
cultures is you get a wider perspective
and uh absolutely for instance sometimes
uh talking to the iranian test buyers
yes there you go
they're just as upset or obviously not
just as upset but more upset about some
things that their government might be
doing then uh
then you would otherwise
yeah you know you you can be surprised
that uh
obviously uh you know people right
rooting for bobby it kind of makes sense
right if you think about it more deeply
exactly quietly
right and i love the story uh recently
from a v friedman a famous chess coach
here in the united states he goes to all
of these scholastics world champions
world championships and he had gone to
the united arab emirates but he had a
israeli visa on his passport and so he
was clearly being admitted into the
country
and
he was
not concerned per se but his safety
was in question and then he was walking
around with the locals just talking to
them about israeli politics and he was
really pleasantly surprised that
actually their views were very similar
with the views of the locals i thought
that was a very humorous story in fact
yeah that's right i mean it's uh one of
the most controversial things that in
some of these v-day tournaments uh
uh some countries they can't prepare it
against israel but usually that's coming
from the government not from the players
themselves the players would love to
play exactly they just they like to play
so these are really political things
that are keeping the players apart but
uh unfortunately i mean fortunately it's
pretty rare yeah well i was just going
to say with many of the cuban players in
particular i like a lot of the cuban
players and i've had great battles with
some of the cuban grand masters and i
found them very very engaging
individually and yet our governments are
so opposed to one another it's like we
can't be friends okay let's let's be
friends anyway
direct flight from uh new york to
youtube
we have another question i think that
we're going to try to get up here and
hashtag us at u.s chess champs
um and this one is from chess.com the
question is most girls that i know are
interested in clothing dolls etc
but i'm sure that when you were young
chess was big for you
how did chess and the saint louis chess
club become such a big part in your life
right that's a great question well you
know actually when i was really young i
my brother was such a talented and
promising player that i actually wasn't
involved in chess
when he became a master it took me a
little bit longer
so i was uh about eswaran's age when i
started to get more into it really so i
think that's good for people to know
because
you know a lot of times they think that
if you don't show promise at the very
beginning it's hopeless right that's not
the case i didn't show a lot of problems
at the beginning and yet i uh you know
still was able to
get the master rating at 16 after
really getting into it when i started
realizing how much fun chess was right
you know so that's the thing you don't
want to compare yourself to other people
and say like i'm not
this good so i won't be able to uh be a
champion just
getting through the game right well
fall in love with it and then the rest
will come usually those people who are
thinking about results and rewards are
not the ones who are succeeding it's the
ones that just love chess right well
i'll steal a little bit of your thunder
in to inform the questionnaire
questioner that of course you're a daddy
mike you know one of the strongest
players in pennsylvania and
philadelphia champion
a
strong strong master
played chess most of his life i believe
so you had to have so chess was always
around even if you weren't interested
per se until 1213 that you kind of got
into it you were aware
that your dad and your brother were
playing chess and you knew what was
going on that's right and that does help
a lot and that's why it's nice to have
chess in the schools have the st louis
chess club as a resource so that if the
family doesn't play chess you can get
that chess community elsewhere right so
um
great question and we've got something
from grandmaster maurice ashley
indeed jen some interes interesting
developments happening on
a few boards that we should take a look
at let's start here at the top board on
the women's side abrahamian has played
crush as you mentioned 10 times all
those decisive games every time she has
had white it has always been e4 c5 we
know crush plays a sicilian regularly
but it has never been a kalashnikov so
this did surprise abrahamian seeing
crush play like this so let's jump back
to this moment when this position
appeared on the board and abrahamian had
to give a good thing no doubt she had
appeared prepared for crush's normal
lines crush has played e6 early has
played a6 early but never this move e5
with d6
on seeing this abrahamian didn't want to
look too surprised she played c4
something i guess normal for her and
bishop to e7 was played avoiding
bringing the knight out and allowing
sreshnikov lines with bishop to g5 and
after this
bishop to d3 a slightly unusual move
here definitely played
mainly because this knight doesn't want
to end up on this a3 square after its
attack so this move knight c3 which is
the most popular move was not played in
order to give her knight the chance to
go back to the square which is exactly
what happened knight went back to c3 and
now the move bishop to g5 taking a
moment to take advantage of the fact
that this bishop is able to trade itself
off this d6 pawn or the pawn structure
blocks the bishop so now an up a
possible trade here which often gets
blocked knight to d2 is a typical move
here but instead abrahamian put a knight
on a3 anyway we thought she was trying
to avoid this formation she allowed it
anyway now bishop c1 and rook to c1 has
been played so
very new for these players this
particular opening
i'd like to quickly look at this line it
looks as though
eswaran has decided to go for
simplification this is simply not the
main way to play in this moment here
bishop f6 is the most popular move to
keep more minor pieces on the board but
the youngster traded off knight f6
bishop f6 bishop 6 queen f6 and after
knight f3
uh castles queen d2 signaling her
intention of maybe castling on the queen
side satoshi responded with b6 and this
position is definitely fine for black
looking very equal right now those
trades don't leave a great impression so
the youngster is going to have to show
us what she's got planned in that line
and on another board we have not paid
any attention to is this game mullner
robson i really like what's already
starting here some serious action the
pawn has already gone to the square e5
this happened just on the previous move
after bishop to e7 was played this
bishop move
mackenzie
decided let's go i want to see why you
want my pawn on your half of the board
the bishop dropping back so this knight
will end up being rerouted to this other
side but d6 is slightly weak so this
game we want to keep an eye on because
these two players are sharp mulner he's
all about attacking and robson he's all
about tactics so this should be a very
exciting game as well to keep an eye on
here at the championships back to you
guys
thank you maurice i was just going to
say that another
game that's really
caught my fancy is the game between
ocobian and ramirez another heavyweight
match up for this round
and the point there is in the game of
ocobian ocobian's been playing this
opening really slowly with white
which is an indication that
at this point at least
that he's gotten caught in an opening
that he really didn't expect
and let's see why
he's having such difficulties
so
as
we could expect
var he loves queen pawn opening so d4
came out very quickly d5 c4
and c6 slav by uh
alejandro he plays the slav a lot
himself for the opening of the day we've
got that into crucial matchups so
nothing nothing nothing surprising here
knight c3
takes
now this is already the first
surprise for ocobian normally speaking
everybody and i mean everybody in his
brotherhood plays knight f6 this goes
back to the 1930s world championship
matches between max irva and alexander
alekhine
when this capture was originally tried
i've had a number of games as white
myself
where i've gotten huge
opening advantages
after the move e2 e4
threatening to play bishop take c4 it's
a long long
complicated uh variation that goes like
this
i think this was that this variation was
was tried by
um gary kasparov and yvonne sokoloff
in a very celebrated game that gary won
as white but it works out to advantages
for white but ocobian did not play this
challenging move e2 e4 instead he played
knight f3
and this opened up a world of
possibilities for ramirez and i really
like what he did uh alejandro said
listen you're going to give me the pawn
on c4
i'm going to keep it and he played a
very uh savvy little move here e7 e6
so basically what he's saying is that
with this move e6 this bishop on c8 i
intend to play b b7 b5 and keep my pawn
for good
uh okobian started thinking thinking
thinking thinking thinking and he played
a2 a4 saying i don't want you to play b5
but
but i really like this move now bishop
f8 to b4 because basically with this
bishop coming out and pinning this
knight on c3 uh ramirez is saying i'm
going to play b7 b5
no matter what you do i'm going to be a
pawn up
you
var you got to show your stuff and and
show compensation for the pawn okobian
does not like being down material
and so that's why he's been spending so
much time on this particular opening so
big developments early in this game
maurice you have some insights you'd
like to share
well a fun position happening on one
other board among uh two top players uh
this game between friedel and garev
actually graeve is really the the higher
rated player in this contest and we
talked about him trying to win a game
quite soon and he's played the
hippopotamus opening that's one you
rarely see at this level let me see if i
can get our analysis board right so
let's just go back momentarily we saw
this move knight to c3 and after this
the move a6 followed by bishop e2
this kg move a6 to stop
a piece from going here but more
importantly to prepare the move b5 which
he didn't play he played knight to d7
after this move and after castles e6
avoiding all contact with the pawn at
the top and now the move bishop to g5
and guess what knight to e7 look at
these nights rarely do you see two
knights placed like this actually when
you see it it's in the hippopotamus
that's that's the time you see it
now the move queen d2
potentially preparing to put a bishop on
this square or just to get the rooks
connected and now h6
another feature of this opening and the
bishop dropping back and basically what
white is saying to black is now your
pawns on h6 how are you going to castle
now i've seen this played before i've
even played it once or twice myself
the move b6 and bishop to b7 usually
comes into this opening making it a true
hippopotamus and the king
often plays itself to f8 to g8 to h7 in
order to castle long a long way to go
and it looks like it loses a lot of time
but it's not easy for white to break the
center open any pawn advance one way
will lead to a pawn advance the other
way to keep the center closed so a
tricky opening to play and right now
guerrero played the move knight to f6
this one i don't often see this line get
played this way the knight switching
places coming over to this square
so it's what's interesting about this
opening is that when you play it you can
prepare it as black you think you've
prepared it you're somewhat ready and
then the guy plays natural moves
and it's even harder for you to play
your position because it's easy for
white to make moves but on black side
the position is so unusual that you
really have to have a lot of experience
in it to get your bearings i don't know
if garev has prepared it well enough uh
the grand master who knows his opening
the best would be uh tigar pearson i
believe he's actually this is often
called tiggers or tigers opening if you
will and uh he definitely plays it with
success he's even written a book on it
this is an interesting battle ahead
we'll see how josh friedel handles
himself here against the hippopotamus
back to you guys
well that's funny we actually have a a
comment from uh one of our our tweeters
alexander stuyana from sashos wrote hey
guys do you find the hippo by gray of
somehow disrespectful
oh no no no no no no not at all no no uh
the hippopotamus is a rarity that's for
sure but don't forget in the world
championship match between boris baskey
and tigran petrosian the hippopotamus
was featured
so i mean it definitely has
its admirers the whole idea of the
hippopotamus is to get a very flexible
defense you're giving up a lot of space
of course in the center but the idea is
you
you you're not following the dictates of
theory and a lot of original play can
develop now why the hippopotamus could
be very popular is if you're playing
against a player who's very
theoretically booked up and has a great
deal of knowledge of encyclopedia
knowledge about the openings
you want to get that player out of his
comfort zone out of the openings that he
studied and get him to play his own
original moves and in this case timor i
really actually applaud him for this
because josh
is not one of the higher ranked players
in the field certainly josh would have
come to this event very well prepared
spent months in training in fact and so
timor is basically saying look i'm going
to give you the advantage in the opening
but guess what you're just going to have
to outplay me
to keep that advantage so i think it's a
it's a it's a perfectly legitimate
choice especially when white doesn't
have moves
openings
that could feature f4 or c4 only e4 and
d4
very flexible
and when i was growing up by the way the
hippopotamus as well as what we call the
rat
was a defense i like to play very often
with black and
i i played in early a6 and b5
as well wow hippopotamus sounds a lot
better than a rat
yeah but the rat is a pretty amazing
animal you know i mean it can survive a
lot a rat
um one way to look at it and with that
let's take a quick commercial break all
right we'll be right back with more from
the u.s championship
welcome back to the 2014 us chess
championship we've got our our game
lenderman really a key game for the
standings ken lenderman continue to
impress the field that's right i mean
you can't maintain his lead he's playing
against shanklin and yasser you were
saying that you
really like the way that this opening
has turned out for for sam oh yes
definitely very much so if it it feels
to me that
alex who has
really relied
upon his
opening preparation to get an early edge
in his games
and he's done so very successfully has
been caught
in today's game
i was explaining earlier that this line
of play with the bishop coming to f4
allows black an early c7 c5
when sam played that c7 c5 it seemed to
catch uh lenderman by surprise
and the move rook takes d4 this just
feels wrong what on earth is the rook
doing in the center of the board
vulnerable to e6 e5 types of attacks and
sam jumped all over that move with the
move queen a5 indeed with ideas like
capturing on c4 and once again playing
e5 and then alex just basically lost a
tempo with this
voluntary retreat so to speak rook on d4
to d1 and i'm saying they're saying my
goodness white's king
still in the center the bishop on f1 is
not ready to jump out of the center
anytime soon i'm thinking that after a
move either rook d8 which is a nice
little
reasonable move but even the very
aggressive and looks to me a highly
desirable move knight b6 could be played
attacking the pawn on c4 white does not
want to capture on d5 knight takes d5
with an attack against the knight on c3
the bishop on f4
and i'm already thinking that black is
cruised past
the equality and would actually stand
better
slightly better if this position were to
occur on the board in other words i
think sam is just as pleased as police
can be
with the outcome of this opening
well look at his pastor he's uh he does
have that feeling of like a bird of prey
right he's ready to jump
pounce i mean so we better go get some
of that green juice better you better
fill up right so again
a very nice uh opening uh choice by sam
is being rewarded
uh
today
another game that actually it's from
it's from the women's event it's the
game between victoria knee and nemkova
that also got my attention because
when i was preparing
for my match that was played here in
saint louis
a match funnily enough i kind of dreamt
about when i was
young
playing anatoly karpov
a match um
but it was supposed to be for the world
championship that just didn't occur
i had prepared this pawn sacrifice the
very pawn sacrifice that victoria is
playing to today i have prepared for
anatoly and essentially we'll go back to
the start of the position for a second
and the players played all of these
standard moves that came from what we
call a queen's indian defense and this
is one of the most popular one of the
one of the positions that
anatoly karpov defended um
his whole career and
i like this idea of d4d5 this was
introduced by grand master left paulie
polyeske this pawn sacrifice white
advance says right into the teeth of
black's defenders
bishop on b7 pawn on e6 knight on f6
all defending the the d5 square and
white plays d4 d5 anyway captures on d5
knight
uh h4 this was really
the gem
behind lev's
pawn sacrifice approach
the bishop on g2 has opened up that
diagonal pinning the pawn on d5 and
preparing the knight jump knight f5 you
get some fantastically
complex battles out of this pawn
sacrifice
so victoria really i feel like rory
played this against me once did he
really victoria's husband yuri
or maybe i saw like him it looks really
familiar from yuri shulman he played it
against me too okay yeah dupont
sacrifice he played it against me in the
u.s championship as well and and yuri is
great at this kind of opening exactly so
something uh victoria made
actually we kind of miss him here he's
something he's had fantastic
performances in the us champion he's a
good time big time uh
right now he's taking care of the little
one gabe that's right and also just like
with a 12 player field and so many
strong players kind of switching
federations it's just harder and harder
to get into the championship but you
never would have thought it would be
hard hard for somebody who's you know
second place two years in a row
absolutely and playing on the us olympic
teams world teams my goodness yeah we
kind of like outperformed his rating a
lot of times in the championship there's
some people who just like that
just kind of like ownership and cobia
are a little bit the opposite like it's
not that they underperform but they're
usually not in contention even though
their ratings would suggest that
eventually they would be right they play
at some very solid level where other
players are spiking yeah
that's right
we've got more from maurice
i just wanted to focus on the top board
on the women's side a grand master arena
crush playing against a favorite
customer almost of hers tatev abrahamian
who is trying for a breakthrough against
irina of course tatev has defeated her
before but the score is kind of lopsided
between the two of them so
she's trying to make sure she does not
get surprised irina played this funky uh
variation well it's a known variation
but she's just simply never played it
against tatev before and now she's
plunked her knight in on the d4 square
she took some time to get here it's one
of those minuses of playing an opening
you've never played before is when the
lines start to deviate from what you
prepared now you have to go on your own
but your experience is not there to help
you because you've never played the
opening before so tativ no doubt has
seen that his abrahamian has no doubt
seen this as white before this kind of
setup before
but crush has to be on her own now so
she's put her knight on the d4 square
which uh houdini is saying is just fine
i want to bring up the form
from yesterday that irina crush showed
in her game against camilla bug and
skyte if you haven't seen it it's just a
wonderful miniature to take a look at
let's examine it here in this position
crush had white and she proceeded to
play some beautiful moves she started by
trading on e4 and now this pawn was
under attack from the rook and the queen
so pawn takes was forced and instead of
moving the knight she started with this
very nice move rook to d5
testing the queen as to where it would
go it could not go on this side also
could not play the move queen to e7
because the rook would come down again
ignoring this knight and attacked both
the queen and the bishop so instead she
was forced to put her queen on the other
side of the board queen to c8 which now
put four pieces four black pieces on
this queen side
crush was quick to take advantage of
that with the move knight to g5 and now
she was threatening the very powerful
queen h5
with a vicious mating attack a foot
the best move was probably h6 at this
moment willingly uh giving away a pawn
in the main line i'll show it to you h6
what could have been played and after
queen two h5 taking this piece rook
takes so much pressure on this pawn that
you'd have to give the piece back in
this line a line that you showed
yesterday yasser after these moves
white is up a pawn but has to prove
herself after this queen to c2 move
because black could get some counter
play and fight trying to fight out his
sturdy defense instead of doing that
after knight g5 bugging sky to play
something miserable the move f6
this one made irina crush's eyes go wide
open and she quickly played the move
rook to d7 knowing that her knight was
completely immune if pawn takes knight
then queen to d5 check and the king
wherever it goes is going to get
checkmated by a bishop a vicious finish
so instead of that after rook to d7
realizing that she couldn't touch the
knight she tried to bring her own knight
over to this side but it did not help
because of this beautiful queen to h7
queen to h5 move threatening 87 and also
f7 leaving a rook hanging the rook was
captured queen to f7 check king to h8
and then the beautiful bishop takes on
f6 and the position that exploded around
black's king no defense no satisfying
defense against the mate on g7 obviously
you can't capture because of queen takes
eight seven mate also rook to g8 is not
playable because of the simple queen
back to h5 with lots of mate threats one
queen eight seven the second knight to
f6 knight to f7 and if h6 in this
position queen takes is mate just a
vicious vicious finish on arena crush's
part she's sawing tremendous form in
this event which is why she's a
five-time champion for one thing but
looking every bit of a champion imagine
six-time champion
wow
yes i know you're a four-time champion
that's pretty amazing a great
accomplishment if she were to do it
still a lot of a lot of play in the
tournament and that key gain coming up
between arena and anna as well
i've been keeping my eye on the game of
our leader alex lenderman against sam
shankland and pretty much as expected
sam did play this move knight
uh d7 b6 which i
thought he would uh trying to force
white to resolve the tension in the
center
lenderman was forced to play the move
knight f 3 to d2
keeping his pawn on c4 protected and now
sam
is seizing the initiative with the move
bishop e7b4 putting pressure on the e1
to a5 diagonal and
possibly threatening to simply capture
this pawn on c3 one of the interest
intriguing things about this move is as
white you may get the wrong impression
that with the move knight on d2 to b3
that you're
winning
black's queen there are lots of lots of
lines where queen takes a2
is possible
because this knight on c3 is an absolute
pin but
when you attack the queen strangely
enough you could actually force it even
to a more effective square for example
even like the a4 square here so
basically it's a bit of a fight for a
tempo
if white plays a2 a3 we'll see a big
liquidation
on the c3 square and i'm sure sam will
be satisfied with the outcome of this
opening
and if white plays the move
uh just a second pardon me if white
plays the move bishop e2
then the fight for the tempo has been
won by black and i reckon that after
captures knight takes knight takes
bishop takes
b7 b6 once again black has a very
comfortable
position out of the opening so
still
i think the pressure is on lenderman
in this particular game and our other
key marquee match-up on board two
between our heavyweights alexander
oneishook and goddakamski
so far
nothing's been traded
the position is what we would call a
closed position
all 16 pawns are on the board and the
players seem to simply have been
rearranging their pieces through the
opening move so still
everything to play for in this key match
up white's a little bit better thanks to
once again his advantage in space
a little bit to my surprise this night
stayed on d7 and it didn't go to the
square b4
so i'm going to give white a little edge
but black's position is ultra solid and
once again godokanski plays these
positions better than anybody in the
world he just loves the black side of
these closed positions where it's
strategical play
that decides not tactics not
combinations just good solid chess
and do you think white has a normal
opening advantage here yes but nothing
beyond that the problem is is where
exactly should you play one of the
one of the ideas behind this queen
having gone uh cleverly to b8 is to
support the bishop so for example let me
just go want back one move uh
alex played h2h3 making look for his
king
protecting the square g4 had alex gone
immediately
for the move e three e4 breaking in the
center it's strange that white breaks in
the center but guess what it's blacks
pieces that come
alive not whites
after all of those trades the move c6 c5
and then suddenly you just take a look
at the position for a moment and this
sleeping bishop
that was dormant this sleeping bishop
are now on two
really nice sweeping diagonals and it's
not easy for white if white missed times
i meant to say his break e3 e4 black can
get a very good game
quite quickly
with this counter c6 c5 so alex is under
he has to find
a deep plan
to
make such a break of e3 e4 effective
because he's so hard to beat his face
yeah because if you miss time it
the advantage can just swing that
quickly so still a stodgy position
trench warfare going on in our game two
battle
let me just and uh we're going to take a
quick break and we have a as usual one
of our bobby fischer positions ah puzzle
of the day let's see we're gonna have
multiple puzzles today so
can i stay tuned and you're gonna
hopefully learn a lot can i win a
membership
sure okay great that's not fair to the
audience
so
and we are back at the 2014 u.s chess
championship and u.s women's and sorry
to everybody at home who wasn't able to
access us in the last half hour or so
we've had some difficulties haven't we
yeah a little bit of a pawn storm or i
think actually so many people all over
the world logging in
that could be crashing
we uh thank you those of you who for
staying with us and
uh we're excited about the day
keep questions and
comments coming
u.s chess champs comments at st louis
chessclub.org
well today we've had some major matchups
in the women's championship the four
leaders are all playing against one
another in the men's championships
again lenderman shankland kamsky
onishuk big games but i'm actually
intrigued by the game between
josh friedel and timor garriev
only because timor has played this very
uh rare
uh defense the hippopotamus and i'm just
mystified by black's last move let me
just go back to this moment
b2b4 is a common move in this type of
position as white denies black any
opportunity to play b5 b4 chasing the
knight attacking the pawn on e4 so b4
everything's fine with that move but
then
this very bizarre bishop
uh
b7 to c6 i just
i haven't seen that move i have a
massive massive tournament experience
and i actually played this variation
with black i've never played bishop c6
in this movie this was a very very deep
move or timor is simply barking up the
wrong tree with this move a much more
standard move for for black maurice
mentioned the castling by hand king f8
to g8 to h7 to protect this h6 pawn
another common idea for black in this
specific position
is to play g6 g5 very ambitious move
blunting the battery against the h6 pawn
black prepares to castle
as well as to play moves like knight e7
to g6 so this move bishop c6 which was
played in the game is just
i've been
troubled by it uh don't quite uh follow
it i'm sure josh didn't get the idea
either he just played rook fe1 and said
please show me what you're doing and
please explain to our audience what your
bishop is doing on c6 while uh you're
trying to figure out a plan yeah let's
try to figure out what could it be it's
so strange well the only thing i can
imagine is if you go back to this
position
timor may have
been concerned about white playing a2 a4
again i see the move b2 b4 as being just
a defensive move to stop black from
playing
b4 so the move bishop c6 may be
directed that okay you can't play a4
because of captures you can't capture
because once again this pawn on e4 would
be hanging in that case
so
if white
isn't playing for a4 which i don't think
white is by the way
and instead white just brings everything
to the center rook f1 to e1 rook on a1
to d1
white has an extremely
a very very harmonious position and
black still has to solve the question of
what he's doing with this king
that's right i mean that's a beautiful
center usually we have to pay a little
bit more to get us into that right and
that's what happens when you play kind
of offbeat opening unorthodox like to be
hippopotamus with that well you're
taking risks clearly
yeah
so a lot of children you know they like
to play openings based on the opening
name right so the hippopotamus the
dragon
the cooler sounding the name the more
likely they are to play it so the rat
doesn't qualify in that case does it i
don't know the rat is kind of a cool
sounding name that sounds like
just uh dirty
dirty usually is a good a good thing in
a
in poker at least i think in chess too
you know it means you're playing kind of
like sneaky moves right
um let's just uh take a quick look at
the game between our leader uh alex
lenderman he's up against sam shanklin
i've been saying that uh
how shankland
handled the opening very well in my
pardon me uh shanklin has handled the
opening very well in my opinion and
um alex has been living off of his
spoils that he's been getting from his
opening preparation he has not done well
today in my opinion let's just go back
when we had left the position
it was back at these parts
knight b6 knight d2 bishop b4 came a3
and i had mentioned that after all of
these trades
bishop d7
we got a position
like this now
takes pawn takes and white has
a problem how is he going to protect his
pawn on c3 he can't simply bring his
bishop back to b4 protecting the pawn
because that will simply run into the
obvious a5 chasing away the bishop
after a move like rook c1 defending the
pawn while black is quick to pounce with
rook c6
gaining a tempo against the bishop on d6
followed by the immediate rook on a8 to
c8 doubling up on the defile against
this weakness on c3 and again black sees
the initiative and i prefer his game and
this
all came out of the opening to attack
that pawn on c3 than it is to attack the
the pawn on d5 right exactly the
weaknesses here
is uh just more juicy for black really
really telling in his favor and how do
you think uh concretely how do you think
white's going to deal with this
it's not going to be easy
if and i'm not suggesting that this is a
the way that
lenderman will want to play the position
lenimon may have to jettison upon
because if he starts going backwards
in an in a really gross way
and plays a move like knight b1 bringing
his knight back to the first rank i mean
he's just inviting black to bring his
knight to c5
to e4 possibly even
following up with knight uh c4 every
single one of black's pieces looks
better than every single one of whites
and that's always a bad sign and why why
is that a big surprise uh look at all of
white's pieces still on in their
barracks another random game yeah this
is not
what you would expect to see from a
player who's not only leading the
tournament but having a tournament
performance rating way up there in the
stratospheres of the 2800 classes so a
bad outing uh almost from just a bad
opening did you see him there he
actually just went like that like uh oh
like like he he
he caught the point oh like he noticed
something yeah
definitely not happy sometimes players
become a little bit more animated
when they're
in trouble well this is the first time
to control themselves true and this is
the first time that alex lenderman has
been in real pressure in this
championships
and um they will be interesting to see
how he handles that pressure because if
sam could rope him back into the pack
look at that chasing pack
onisha kamsky gauriev
okobian all standing at plus one and i'm
sure they're rooting for shanklin to do
very well in this game shall we see also
the
the heavyweight matchup
last time we looked literally nothing
had been traded
in this case a single
exchange has been made the bishops have
been traded we go back a little ways to
about these parts and i was explaining
why
the early e3 e4 could rebound against
white and that is what white wants to do
is to advance in the center
in just a second after we get some moves
that's an interesting look at even
though he's in a cramped position look
at how uh
gotta is maneuvering
rook on a8 to a7
remarkable little rook lift there
followed by
after bishop d3 again white is clearly
aiming for e3 e4
bishop back to a8 so that this rook
can eventually
come on over into the center of the
board rookie one again great
patience
by chilling too
and relaxed well he really does want to
get in this move e3 e4 and he wants to
make sure his pieces are ideally placed
oh i mean kamsky looks relaxed oh in the
game bishop f8
okay so this bishop on a3 gotta felt was
doing uh more work than the bishop on f8
so trading off one of his opponent's
effective pieces
knight d2 further preparation i mean how
many how many times is he going to
reinforce
the advance e3 e4 before he actually
plays it exactly good question and i can
tell maurice ashley this is his favorite
type of position oh sure gorillas and
chills maurice what do you got for us
yeah this is when i get the pillow and
start playing scrabble
i mean this one locked deadlocked this
is kamsky's favorite kind of position
when he's defending because he knows
it's very hard to pierce his formation
so i don't expect anything from
ownership in this game it looks like
he's happy to just play real solid
typical of his style but so minimalist
that it looks like it's not going to do
anything to kamsky who
yesterday surprisingly said that it
looks like we're going to have a new
champion this year that was a statement
that took all of us uh by shock i mean
we said what how can the champion be
saying that and especially after he
played a very nice game against sergey
aronberg in round four of the
championship just wanted to go back to
that position to show the fans who
haven't seen it here kamsky played the
very nice move rook to d6 plunking his
rook down on a super square this is
usually bad news for the defender when
you see a rook land in the middle of
your heart like that and you can't
capture it well he could have taken it
he chose it chose not to because after
takes takes his pawn sacrifice queen to
f6 just ties everybody up this knight
can't move these pawns are under attack
a tremendous position for white so here
ehrenberg after rook to d6 decided to
play h5 this is just tossing pawns
because it's kamsky's position for
choice here he moved his rook over to d1
and now the rook was solidly cemented on
that square and after f4 he still didn't
worry about that he played the move
queen to c4 preparing a very nice
sacrifice in case of pawn takes pawn he
would have won a piece with this queen
take on this square and now queen takes
queen is not playable because of rook
takes rook rook takes and then just
simply trading down and ending up a
piece ahead of course this extra night
so in this position after queen to c4
the king moved over to c8 and then
kamsky played g takes g takes and then
just kept the power moves look at those
pieces magnificently centralized in the
heart of black's position black played
this move a blunder not realizing the
next move was coming it didn't matter
much anyway rook takes c5 of course you
can't take because you just drop your
queen so after after rook takes c5 he
had to go back grovel back into the
corner and then the other rook posted in
the heart on the seventh rank of the
position hitting the queen knight takes
rook is of course unplayable because of
queen takes queen and there's just
brutal threats of checkmate on this line
about to appear the knights hanging i
mean any normal move could lead to just
total pain after a move like queen to d5
or other ideas in the position so black
decided right here to call it quits
kamsky showing his power chest this is
certainly his kind of chess position he
loves to play chess in this way and
sometimes though
often you'll see him play with black
very solidly very cagey just you know
i'm not going to do anything i'm just
going to let you try to do something so
i can defend well and it looks like
onishak is really up against it but he
knows what kind of monster chest this
guy can play so you can understand why
you see him being really cautious maybe
too much of an abundance of caution
respecting this four-time champion for
the tremendous fighter that he is back
to you guys
yeah i don't really blame either of the
players i think it's an unfortunate
clash of styles yes or rather than clash
of style's match of styles like two
matchy matchy exactly exactly that was
one of the reasons why i thought the
matches the five world championship
matches between karpov and kasparov was
so engaging
because karpov had this iceman-like
style this wonderful technical position
versus the fiery and sacrificial uh gary
kasparov tactics galore and so
the clash of their styles was
fantastic um and by contrast we see the
irena crush tatev abrahamian 10 decisive
games something about their styles
always creating interesting chess and
very double-edged positions as well
bringing out either the best or the
worst in both players that their
matchups like i
i don't think i've ever had an opponent
where all the games between us were
decisive i had a lot of decisive games
one some lost some with larry
christensen but we also had
a number of draws as well in our in our
uh head-to-head
beautiful red and purple combination
we need to borrow that idea uh-huh
you had a good quote for us yeah i
wanted us to while i pulled that quote
up i wanted us to uh go back to the
grave game oh right and so gray of uh
just a point behind you know he had a
very disappointing loss yesterday
um but he's the kind of guy who seems
like he can bounce back quick
yes yes uh and today he chose an unusual
opening today he played the hippopotamus
but as you pointed out it's been played
in world championship matches
and
also
um the grandmaster from sweden tiger
hillar person has written a book about
it
so a tiger playing an animal chess
opening that makes sense right right and
what he said is
the hippo lies low in the water
it looks almost ridiculously passive
and many theoreticians consider the
hippo to be a peaceful almost meek
animal
but nothing could be further from the
truth
on closer scrutiny the animal the
position and the statistics look almost
entirely different the hippo is a fierce
animal
ready to crush anyone who gets too close
ooh nice and by the way in africa the
hippo
is one of the animals that kills more
human beings
than lions
i think that must have been a reference
to that yeah there you go
and by the way since you had mentioned
the timor-gariev game and i did bringing
it up on our screen
uh timor played this very mystifying
move bishop c6 normally it's like the
mysterious rook move or the wrong rook
move going to the wrong rook going to
the to the right square type of thing
and after queen d7 josh was very happy
to just
play straight through the center if you
look at the position from white's point
of view all of white's pieces are
ideally placed if you will in the center
and then suddenly you're ready for this
move bishop c6 to b7
it's sort of like timor saying
i really don't know what i should be
doing
and he just moved his bishop back and
forth
because you can just see that black has
lost two tempe essentially for nothing
that was why what maurice was saying and
this whole idea of
castling by hand even though it's a
tempo it's a maneuver that's going to
cost three tempe
because the position is so closed uh
black can get away with that maneuver
but moving your bishop back and forth
without encouraging some
very
snazzy uh pawn sacrifices uh
timor's playing with fire
well
i have looked it up and the hippopotamus
is the fifth most deadly animal there
you go and it's uh just ahead of the
scorpions i'm just behind scorpion
scorpions are slightly more deadly okay
and snakes so you wouldn't be surprised
by that
so the hippopotamus uh but actually
there's a massive gap it's kind of like
nakamura in the rest of the championship
the snake is really really dangerous oh
yeah and then there's a big gap between
the hippo and the uh scorpion so
survival skills for you guys out there
okay if you have a choice avoid snakes
avoid scorpions and stay away from
hippos exactly right i once got chased
by a hippo actually oh my god thank god
you're still with us yeah well i was in
a car
so it was a very good it was a very good
it was a jeep pardon me uh but it was a
very good thing i was in the gym
yeah i was on a safari uh
the hippo there was a i didn't realize
that there was a calf
and the jeep uh got too close to the
calf and mama came charging
yeah it was very dangerous well you know
the number one those people
people people
people versus people okay so let's take
a look at uh irena crush um abrahamia
and we just made a remark about their
styles we didn't actually get a chance
to look at the game last time we checked
it was a kalashnikov as maurice earlier
pointed out crush
always trying to seize the initiative
against tata of abraham and play the
sicilian why not she's had eight
decisive wins against tatev right so
decisive games and she's usually on top
but i will tell you that the ones that
have won have been memorable yeah you
want a really sweet sicilian but that
was a more traditional silly and you
know opposite side castling just kind of
really tatev's cup of tea oh wow okay
very can imagine that with that hair
that she likes to attack right yeah yeah
but sometimes looks are deceiving
actually um
my father one of the more uh you know
sedate players you can't always tell and
yet he was running iron man so he looked
like a really an athletic player he was
about to try to bash your head in but
instead
slow style english
he liked to take over the squares he
liked he liked it and then you mentioned
ray robson right you know very kind of
mild-mannered i i was trying not to say
me because i feel like that's like
slightly negative yeah that's what they
used to say about superman right clark
kent he was meek mild-mannered clark
kent
here we got the game now so right so
what do you think we mentioned earlier
that usually white has a positional edge
here and it's black who ends up getting
the activity
if she can find a way to play f5 at the
right moment right let's just go back a
few moves because we came out of the
opening and it was this uh
intriguing idea bishop g5 early to get
rid of this dark square bishop by arena
she has pawns on d6 and e5 so from a
strategic point of view it made sense
for her to try to trade dark square
bishops
and after a couple of standard moves
this knight
went to the center white's knight went
into the center knight d5 castles king
h1
hmm
i don't like that move bishop d7 queen
d2 b5 and we're up to date on the board
and actually i still
think that white has a slight pull here
i wouldn't
give her too much of an edge
i would want to get rid of this knight
on d4 so the move knight a3 to c2 i
would find attractive and i was just
thinking about what would happen
in this exact moment if white decided to
try to trade all the knights off the
board if black were to cooperate well
one of the things that white would be
very happy about is this rook being on
the open c file it's oops that my arrow
is terrible
easy to double on the c file for white
giving her an advantage so i still like
uh tatiaf's position i'm not so sure
about that king h1 move just trade all
the knights and go into a sedate
positional game not her forte because
like you say she likes to attack but
that is getting stronger so becoming
more of a universal player now she has
all of her i am norms
i think uh and she's actually been very
vocal about
in some of our interviews with the past
that she's more interested in the i am
and jam title than the wgn title so i'm
sure absolutely she'll be really happy
when that officially changes i think
she's
got the norms maybe
i believe she even went over the ratings
so probably just waiting for fide to
recognize it to confirm her um
international master title nice which is
just a tad bit
harder to get than the wgm usually it
requires a half a point more
in a tournament performance so a lot of
times somebody will score a wgm norm and
an iamnor right so it's kind of typical
that somebody will have both titles but
um you know it took her an extra year or
so to get the the full im title got it
got it and uh how about we check in our
13 year old and while we bring that up
our estherisa eswarad who's been
shocking us with her inspired play
i will point out we got a couple of good
comments from
antonio fedez ander who said
that the mosquito is the most deadly
animal by far
good point
malaria yes uh
gotta luckily there is no mosquito
opening in chats
and uh he also
made another comment earlier he asked us
if blitz games are good for studying
openings any advice about hal and he's
from
pontia spain wow i don't know where that
is but it sounds nice somehow i'm
imagining some beautiful beaches right
i'll look it up later and i actually i
actually believe that blitz games are
excellent for studying openings and i
hope my student who's the founder here
at the chess club rex singfield is
listening because i'm constantly nagging
him to play more
blitz just so that he can kind of blitz
or 15 minute i even prefer 15 minute but
sometimes it's harder to get those games
just so that you can kind of test
yourself what do you really remember
right because if you're just uh kind of
like inputting things into chess base
and looking for a book
it's like you might think you remember
it because it's right there in front of
you but do you really remember it when
the clock is ticking and the pressure's
on right and then you get that
experience
of maybe losing in a certain line and
it stays with you you remember it and
you know what you need to fix
so i
absolutely believe that blitz games and
rapid games are very good for your
openings
and we've got something from maurice
thanks jen a very important development
with our leader he is now down upon
not looking good for him he decided yes
that it was much better to not defend
the position not just sit there and
suffer but rather just ditch the pawn
and try to defend that way down a pawn
so in this position after black played e
takes d5 white didn't try to play rook
c1 and try to hold upon that couldn't be
held anyway uh or you'd have to go
through all sorts of contortions
bringing a knight back to b1 in order to
hold on to it
linderman said forget the pawn i'm just
going to try to harmonize my pieces he
played night over first the move rook to
c6 was played bishop to e7 and now the
grab of the pawn and now he dropped back
with bishop to b4 and now rook back to
c7 so at the moment white is just down a
clean pawn
just count him six to five that's it he
does have the two bishops this bishop
may potentially be a strong piece but a
pawns a pawn after all so lindemann has
to be terrified of this position right
now he's gonna have to show some skills
defending that one we did see the
maneuver in the friday goray of game
that we talked about the hippopotamus is
typical the king started to march over
to the side of the board it should be
noted however when the king gets on h7
it will be having to eyeball this bishop
on d3 so
strange things could happen along that
diagonal black has to be really careful
here white often likes to somehow get
this pawn up to h4 and h5 at the moment
though he would need a knight to be on
this side of the board to pull that off
properly not so easy to get here because
this knight is sturdy grabbing that
square another game
of interest is the game with eswaran and
zatonski as warren played a really tepid
opening to get to this point and now
it's up to zatonski to try to figure out
what to do but she played this move
knight takes on e5 after this position
youngster has been defending quite well
up to this point and now eswaran is
offering her a queen trade essentially
saying you can't really get into my
position the trick being this if queen
takes queen pawn takes and then rook to
d5 trying to win that pawn she has to be
careful because a move like c4 and if
you take the pawn then suddenly rook to
d1 and oops you're losing flat cold a
check's coming and you can't do anything
about it well it was a mate threat but
if you deal with it then you're getting
mated so not so easy to take advantage
of this position right now for black so
it looks like the youngster might have
solved most of her problems and may be
on her way to equalizing drawing someone
like a four-time champion in zatonski
would be an amazing feat for his war on
she'd be happy to walk out of here
very standing very much standing proud
to and i know her parents would be
thinking yeah if you're drawing them now
imagine what you'll be doing in a couple
of years so a good situation for her the
pressure's on zatonski however to see if
she can make something of this position
with the black pieces back to you guys
oh you know earlier in the broadcast we
had somebody uh write in about uh
getting more girls into chess and you
know
i was lucky enough that uh a couple
years ago i actually gave a simultaneous
at the north cal
house of chess which is where eswara and
the sisters us you know learned and
became better in the beginning
yeah well uh outside san francisco
outside frisco story i'm not sure the
exact city uh fremont i believe okay and
uh that was a opening for my book play
like a girl so i gave a little simul and
her little sister is also very strong i
heard she's going to be visiting
so it's great to see
you know these uh these young girls kind
of inspired an early age i think a lot
of young girls watching this broadcast
will look at her and
after they listen to us for five hours
they're gonna
study more chats